former xerox chief executive ursula
burns made history in 2009 as the first
african-american woman ceo of a fortune
500 company
she spent 36 years at xerox working her
way
from engineer all the way to the top
during the obama administration burns
also led the white house
stem program for seven years making her
a champion of science and technology
along with engineering and math that's
what stem stands for today burns serves
on the boards of uber
exxon mobil nestle the mayo clinic and
mit among others her new memoir
where you are is not who you are details
her path to success
and i'm happy to say ursula burns joins
us now ursula good morning
good morning anthony nice to be here i
really appreciate you being here
it's a very sharp a sharply observed and
blunt book
the title where you are is not who you
are is fantastic it's a lesson from your
mother a single mom
it's good because it works where you are
now but also where you started
how did it help you in your career
i had to always remember during my rise
my rise to the top per se that
that those circumstances of you know as
i progressed
were only a portion of you know who i
was myself i had to actually always
remember
that people around me even if they
didn't have as much as i had
or had more um were worthy of
attention and being listened to et
cetera it was my mother's way of saying
that
don't get too big for your britches
right stay in make sure that you
understand
that humans are humans and that they
require or deserve
respect and and keep being cared for
yeah your mother had a lot of
instructions that helped you along the
way and you also
point out that xerox the company you
worked at for so long was a pioneer in
diversity but
i'm curious what do you think holds back
all the other potential
ursula burns is out there from getting
the opportunities that you got along the
way
yeah i think that there are two words
one the words that you use hold back is
one
right they just start we start in a
different place we start
generally with poor educational
institutions poor health care less food
or work or bad food
all of the starting points that launch
you into life
are scarce if you live in poverty
safety as comfort those types of things
that's one set
the other is that there are people who
have power today who prefer to keep it
and the institutions and the structures
and the processes
that we use to govern to make decisions
to choose
are all based on a historic
look and feel that's generally the white
male look and feel
don't get me wrong i like white males
it's just that right now the world
it has always been but now it's pretty
obvious that the world has been tilted
in their favor
for a very long time and we have to
actually adjust it
a bit to make it a more quote unquote
level playing field
at least from the start ursula last time
you were on cbs this morning you had
just co-signed a letter with other
executives against restrictive voting
laws in georgia
since then more states have moved to
restrict voting access are you concerned
that corporations aren't having enough
influence
i am concerned that they're not saying
enough and therefore not having enough
influence
the vote the voting restrictions in my
opinion this is definitely
personal they're shameful i mean one of
the things that i think about when i
think about america everybody thinks
about when they think about america
is fundamental freedom and the right for
every individual
legally qualified to do so of course has
to select who their leadership
will be who who will represent them and
states across the nation
are making that harder and harder to do
most
most of us try to make it easier and
easier to do not harder and harder to do
so it's a
surprising thing companies must
absolutely must
have a say in this this is not a black
issue this is not a female issue this is
not a brown issue
this is an american issue what more
should they be doing ursula quickly if
you would speaking out
actually getting inv getting involved
and getting engaged having an opinion
i mean this is not a like i said this is
not a political
racial issue this is a this is a
political structural issue
that of course we're interested in we're
interested in trade right we speak about
that
immigration we speak about that we
should we should also be interested
and speak out about things that affect
equality and just good business
practices in
our country as well yeah ursula the book
is concentrated wisdom and a powerful
cultural critique as well thank you for
joining us this morning the book again
is called where you
are is not who you are and it's on sale
right now